die hitze steigt einigen offenbar zu
kopf die nerven liegen blank und jetzt
schon wieder gewalt vor einem deutschen
freibads mit einer eisenstange wird hier
auf dem parkplatz des freibads dortmund
deusen einen mann niedergeschlagen er
wird schwer verletzt es soll um einen
freien parkplatz gegangen sein der
schläger fliegt vom parkplatz wird dann
aber später von der polizei gestellt und
leider war das nicht die einzige freibad
eskalation in diesem jahr
es war nur eine frage der zeit tatort
freibad
am dienstag abend heizt sich ein streit
im berliner columbia bad so auf dass es
mal wieder zu einer massenschlägerei
kommt polizei und feuerwehr rückten mit
einem großaufgebot an und nehmen mehrere
beteiligte fest ein dutzend personen
werden verletzt müssen von den
rettungskräften behandelt werden die
unliebsamen gäste werden des bades
verwiesen doch bei der hitze fällt es
den bürgern offenbar schwer einen kühlen
kopf zu bewahren sie kehren kurze zeit
später wieder zurück versuchen jetzt ins
parteien zu drehen erneut greift die
security ein es kommt zum handfesten
streit der schnell eskaliert sogar
pfefferspray kommt zum einsatz das
schnelle eingreifen der polizei es
beruht vermutlich auch auf den
unfassbaren geschehnissen der letzten
wochen immer wieder bilder wie diese
massenschlägereien und unfassbare
gewaltausbrüche gehören in deutschen
freibädern zum traurigen alltag die
logische konsequenz daraus
zeitaufwendige einlasskontrollen und
dauerbewachung durch security firmen wer
mag ihr noch baden die menschen in den
problemländern sind mittlerweile an
diese bilder gewohnt ist das aus ihrer
sicht jetzt
besorgniserregend dass solche vorfälle
in freibädern häufiger auftreten mit
solchen ausmaßen dann natürlich ist das
besorgniserregend das klingt ja wie
kindergarten dass man sich dann
ernsthaft schlagen muss oder messern zu
stechen musste es ist sehr überhitzt
vielleicht ist es auch dem wetter
geschuldet aber das muss ja nicht sein
viele meiden auch den besuch im freibad
komplett was muss noch geschehen bis die
deutsche politik auf dieses problem
reagiert bleibt nur zu hoffen dass sich
die situation in den freibädern bald
bessern wird ob das diesen sommer noch
mal was wird
und über die sicherheit in unseren
freibädern sprechen wir jetzt mit dem
chef der deutschen polizeigewerkschaft
rainer wendt guten tag herr wendt
erwähnt wie können schwimmbäder und
freibäder sicherer gemacht werden gerade
jetzt wo viele familien viele kinder
dort unterwegs sind ja die
bundesinnenministerium hat ja
vorgeschlagen dass polizei in größerer
anzahl in diesem schwimmbäder sozusagen
von anfang an präsent sein soll das ist
natürlich einigermaßen absurd denn wir
können nicht mit hundertschaften und
jedem freibad sein falls sich irgend
einer dieser typen dazu entschlossen
entschließen sollte eine schlägerei an
ein es sind die badbetreiber in der
pflicht sie müssen wie das ja in ihrem
beitrag auch beschildert ist einlass
kontrollen machen und müssen klar
festlegen werden schwimmbad darf und wir
nicht ran darf das müssen sie auch nicht
begründen sie haben das ausreicht und
das üben sie auch sie sind nicht
verpflichtet ihre privaten party band
all ihrer einzuladen und glauben sie mir
wir wissen wir das ist und wir kennen
die aber ist das nicht auch eine art von
diskriminierung von stigmatisierung in
diesem moment ja die anwendung von
rechts über recht und gesetz ist nicht
immer konfliktfrei diesen vorwurf den
kann ich jetzt schon hören wenn die
polizei das macht nimmt man es dann
wieder recht beteiligen weil es
möglicherweise auch personen mit
migrationshintergrund geht man kann
nicht alles haben wollen also entweder
wie man diese schlägereien unterbinden
in den freibädern da muss man konsequent
dieses bierzelt außen erhalten oder man
muss eben damit leben aber man kann
nicht hunderte von randalierern die man
ja kennt und man weiß was das für leute
sind ins freibad hineinlassen und wenn
es dann klappt muss die polizei so geht
das nicht dass die freibadbetreiber in
der pflicht denn es geht ja darum
diejenigen zu schützen die dort ihre
freizeit verbringen worden kinder bauen
die sind ja völlig verängstigt und wenn
man wie beispielsweise ja auch in berlin
geschehen zu einer kitzbühel party
einlädt und hunderte erwachsene junge
männer dort rein lässt dann hat man auch
eine gewisse verantwortung dafür wenn es
schiefgeht das kann die polizei nicht
leisten übrigens auch die politik der
wende also sie fordern tatsächlich von
den schwimmbadbetreiber gesichts
kontrollen dass sie das tatsächlich am
eingang durchführen ja ich fordere
nichts ungewöhnlich ist das macht jeder
diskothekenbetreiber jeder der einen
ipod oder wie auch immer hat
möglicherweise tür steger und der
entscheidet wer rein darf und will nicht
rein es ist überhaupt kein
ungewöhnliches rechtsinstrument sie
können an ihrer wohnungstür auch
entscheiden wen sie in die wohnung
hinein lassen und nichts anderes ist das
freibad der der betreiber ist in der
verantwortung seine gäste zu schützen
und das beinhaltet halt dass ihr dafür
sorgen muss die hier liegen nicht
einzulassen die möglicherweise gewalt er
rente gehen sie persönlich noch ins
freibad vielleicht auch mit ihrer
familie trauen sie sich da noch hin nein
ich bin nicht ist aber nicht aus diesen
gründen sondern aus ganz anderen gründen
nicht ich springe lieber in den see in
berlin eine gute alternative vielen dank
für ihre zeit und für das gespräch
rainer wendt